Hey, this is a kind of interesting, so some
of you may know that I've been listening to
the Howard Stern show for more than 20 years
when I used to, when I first got my license
in high school, even before then, I would
in the car listen to Howard stern when he
was on terrestrial radio.
He's of course now on Sirius Xm radio and
one of Howard Stern's producers is named Brent
Hatley and he is not only a producer for the
Howard stern show, but he also follows the
David Pakman show.
Brent and I have been in touch for like a
year or two online and I was listening to
the Howard stern show earlier this week.
Uh, and they were talking about how Brent
has been fainting in certain situations and
then recovering pretty quickly.
And as I was listening to it, the circumstances
sounded pretty similar to what I've experienced
in my life.
I had some fainting incidents as a kid and
then just a couple of years ago, our audience
might remember that I actually fainted on
a plane coming back from Italy.
And, uh, it sounded, what I experienced sounded
very similar to what Brent had been experiencing
and I had a cardiology workup to make sure
that my heart was okay.
And it was chalked up to what are called Vasovagal
syncope that have usually been a combination
of having alcohol and coffee in close proximity
to each other at high elevation or on a plane,
which is pressurized to depending on the plane,
somewhere between five and 8,000 feet of elevation.
And so I've stopped doing that and I've been
okay since.
And I told Brent, this is what it sounds like.
And uh, eventually this got me a mention on
the Howard stern show and it's sort of weird
because I medical advice, I was telling Brent
this is how I experienced it and it was very
funny to tune in and to hear Brent say that
David Pakman mentioned that it sounds like
Vasovagal syncope.
Take a listen to this.
Brent, do you ever get a day job boot type
of feeling before you pass out?
That's evidentaly one of the feelings if you
have basil bag, go psychopaths Howard.
I think the Vassar Bagel is the one that Fred
fix.
He may have told him, well, the best advice
I saw out of all the email Brent should see
a cardiologist.
He said they were full workup.
Right.
I had a pacemaker put in at the age of 37.
It was due to my heart not beating for 12
to 16 seconds at a time.
Eye Condition is called complete heart block.
The electrical signals would not pass through
my heart to cause the muscle to pump.
Yeah.
I like, um, you know, this listener says any
doctor would, any good doctor would refer
Brent to a neurologist and a cardiologist.
Full workup.
After passing out.
He kept saying he's fit so they aren't worried
about his heart.
I call bullshit.
Heart issues have nothing to do with fitness.
Yeah.
I don't even think that Brent really went
to a doctor.
Yeah.
I don't know that this person who said smoke
all the pot.
You want.
Yeah.
I mean he found a doctor who feel good.
I think Brent is a hypochondriac.
Well, I think if he's passing out, I don't
proof.
Yeah.
Something could be wrong.
This guy goes, Brenda is a hypochondriac.
All those fainting episodes or fake Brent
is going through a full on midlife crisis.
It's obvious he's going to faint.
It wouldn't be so bad if it happened while
he was on the air boy, a lot of uh, medical,
uh, information.
I did make an appointment with the cardiologist
I talked to.
I talked to one yesterday.
Yes.
And he's going to see me in early July.
He's going to get me in.
So thank you to the show for that because
yes, because that got me into a really good
doctor here in Manhattan.
I, you know, you know, a full workup is a
good idea, pal.
That's what, that's what he said.
He said we're going to do a full workup to
make sure there's no serious heart issues
cause it sounds like a cardiovascular issue.
Yes.
Well look, you know, by the way, Brent refuses
to quit weed for three months.
In fact, there was a post show interview yesterday
that I heard that and can make me a little
sad.
Brent, when I heard this, let me, let me play
it for everyone.
So are you gonna take Howard's advice?
Uh, no.
Why?
Oh, I got stuff coming up that I want to do
and I, uh, you know what, I'd rather have
a medical issue than deal with the, the world.
Why don't you want to deal with the world?
You can just take a look around.
The world is an awful depressing, horrible
place to deal with.
So, you know, marijuana has that in it called
pocket.
Huh?
I've lived a good life.
So if this is a, if I'm not long for this
world, then fine, but if not, Eh, I'm just,
I just do not want to deal with reality,
you know, a or I have found that a lot of
people who say, Hey, you know, and I, I've
lived long enough if, uh, if that's the way
it is, that's the way.
And then as soon as they get diagnosed with
some data, first would you go, I don't want
to die.
You know what I mean?
You don't want to die.
No, I really don't.
Um, but I do actually feel a lot better.
Yesterday after talking to the, you know,
one of the guys that works in my office, not
Julie, his wife has basil Bagel and she talked
to me yesterday, which got me to talk to a
cardiologist and there's a radio guy, I know
a David Pakman sent me a DM and said that
he has basil Bagel.
Right.
And it sounds like the same thing.
So this cardiologist said, let's do a full
workup, let's make sure that's what it is.
Yeah, you're talking pal.
So there it is.
I, I guess I don't even know that there's
that much more to say about it.
It's interesting.
Hopefully Brent gets good news from his cardiologist.
Uh, it is much better to have a Vasovagal
incidents or a tendency to them then to have
some kind of more serious heart issue.
And when I had to wear this a 30 day heart
monitor, which coincided with when I had to
fly back and forth from Las Vegas to this
conference that I go to with other progressive
media hosts and go through airport security
with this heart monitor.
It was a mess.
But my real concern was I hope that I'm not
having this fainting issue because my heart
is stopping for a few seconds altogether.
And I got a clean bill of health and was told
don't drink alcohol and coffee when you're
at elevation.
And uh, that's basically been it.
Knock on wood since then and hopefully Brent
gets the same.
Uh, same
good news.